we're not at war here this look like the
Demilitarized Zone
it's total overkill Ferguson Missouri
looked like this the night of August 13
2014 things look very different in this
small Missouri suburb after the governor
took security duties out of the hands of
local police and Sheriff's Department
and handed it over to State Highway
Patrol
while the atmosphere was free of a
militarized police presence in the mood
of protesters border like celebratory
the resentment towards the police force
that shot and killed 18 year old Michael
Brown seems unlikely to dissipate
anytime soon Michael Brown had no record
juvenile or otherwise and he was shot
down in cold blood
this is this wrong I'm like that is
wrong this time you know we're saying
that I didn't say in st. Louis in a
while it causes you to really think
about you know saying how wrong it is to
be afraid of people who have taken an
oath to serve and protect you people are
getting tie of the police doing whatever
they want to do
I can't say every police officer is bad
wait I haven't made one as good ee
but people here have grown up with this
drug war and they have no known know
almost nothing but from the police
departments but negative energy to get
pulled over non-stop hey man we're the
drugs we're the weapons
rouse you a new cup throw you around and
then oh sorry have a nice day and let
you go because and don't give your
ticket and all you who's gonna believe
you is this type of thing been going on
way before this Michael Brown thing
these police army they harass Wars they
they put tickets on cars that's not even
moving they are writing tickets so fast
and some of these municipalities now
people get a ticket
one day they don't have a court date
until January we simplify the stuff
they've told you $75 for people $100 for
this 100 all today that's what retired
over her to be so afraid that when you
get pulled over for even for for like a
taillight for example you cringe because
of the past their firing was a b-52
pilot we got killed in Vietnam in a war
we're not at war here this look like the
Demilitarized Zone it's total overkill
do you have to shoot tear gas do you
have to threaten people with automatic
rifles in their face put lasers on them
no I don't think you need to do that it
wasn't no it didn't need that you know
we have a
upon test it was faithful I won no
tonight was my question
Vincent you know I'm just processing
people are looking in the rest of the
world you know I'm saying and they see
militarized police and people standing
up against them and in an American in
the American ethos we say are Wow look
at them their freedom fighters but when
the same thing happens here with certain
groups of people and certain ethnicities
it's it's seen as criminal as criminal
when the truth of the matter is the the
most fundamental right that we have that
supports every other right that we have
is the ability to descend the ability to
disagree the ability to speak one's mind
and I think that this gathering is
probably the most the most patriotic
gathering that is happening in Ferguson
right now